il ya une grande star doivent absolument
être sur ce plateau ce soir elle a voulu
rencontrer gilles verdez matthieu
delormeau et bertrand st arnaud roy
c'est mon cadeau
ouvrez les yeux vers caen non mais cyril
je dis ça me laisse carte je suis désolé
et je pète je sais pas bien pour
l'émission mais j'aime ça me gêne que
vous fois qu'on fasse a dit que c'est
pas de l'émission tous devenu viable il
va y avoir des trucs quoi en penser
qu'on va voir des plaintes mais j'en
sais rien mais c'est pas il a été pour
nous bah oui vous voyez là là si vous
étiez sous la table boyer quoi mais je
veux pas voir vraiment j'ai un
communiqué de sart je n'aime pas qu'on
n'ait pas match donc c'est non mais
c'est mapaq viennent plus moche tout nu
gillet pas bouffe
je m'habitue je ramais du tissu j'ai
oubliées j'aime bien je tape oil well as
du ceria qui s'est produit la voix oui
il faut être gentil avec bertrand
l oublier alors attention elle a voulu
être ici en exclusivité dans touche pas
à mon poste ce soir
est ce que vous l'avez vous avez envie
de voir rihanna mathieu rouy cry1ac
rihanna est là gilles verdez rihanna et
bel abbés rencontre sur l'eurozone voir
ses fans je suis pas vous êtes fan de
rihanna
rires et bien rihanna est là ce soir
m
mathieu voulait faire un petit village
où rihanna comme elle est belle
le
je veux jouer
et tweet la twitter m'a pris mon
téléphone m'a laissé attendrir d'elana
est ce que vous les cherry et vous avez
reconnu djezzy au nom
avec jésus est là c'est vrai est-ce que
vous allez chanter une petite chanson à
ses ouailles
malgré la timide et mal qu'est ce que
vous avez fait rien qu'est ce que vous
en avez du derby hamas est le membre
il a même fait un bisou mais non même si
rihanna à you will i like you matthieu
10 mois rihanna elle est belle ou pas
oui non si l'on aille aux biens des faux
messi qu'est ce qu'un accord il m'avait
rien dit à l'ats bertrand qui me pose
une question est ce qu'elle va faire un
live
si ces partis laïques de rihanna
c
gauche
oui
merci
et toi
non
willis et radha même genre et à la
lettone pas parce qu'elle était au
défilé balmain
cette semaine va la bible donc nous les
noms bizarres
pour vous dire que c'est avait il est
exceptionnel un jeu syrienne même en
effet c'était pas de la gare sens le
parti de ne pas rester parce qu'elle
veut plus partir à fond c'est pourquoi
le à doit partir elle doit les rejoindre
sa mère mais dimanche au parc des
princes
il avait dit rien ne vous qui fait il a
cessé de lui demander mais rihanna joue
que faire alors
mais à dallas si kate avec no mercy
gilles verdez merci
ayew
frédéric je sais que c'est des missions
particulières
oui je vois pas ce qu'ils la passent en
hiver quand c'est pas fou rihanna sur le
plateau quant à lui fort basse et fort
vous la trouvez mieux en vrai où la
trouver mieux en vrai ou bien mais en
vrai je n'y aurais aimé plus parler mais
je suis toujours en phase avec judy
milan vraiment déçu de son physique ou
la trouvais belle
franchement mon papa de s'en aller comme
vous l'imaginiez ben moi je trouve ouais
et vous matthieu delormeau quand vous la
trouvez rien a envoyé la photo d'art ou
non elle est belle et pas franchement
c'est face et william d'avancé sur un
plateau en france a juste le truc mais
elle est très très belle la photo
gilbert reste on vous la trouvez rihanna
elle est belle et sympathique pour trait
justin bieber une forte pensée de dieu
non juste enfin c'est pas un léger
rencontre contre elle mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya plus d'ambiance
sur le plateau avec les bogdanoff qu
avec rihanna vous et illustrer ses
gommes des en train de chanter à qui on
dansait il dit c'est ouais ça moi j'ai
dansé mais bon enfin après bon valérie
elle a des petits soucis peut-être mais
je suis sympathique elle est chaleureuse
mais elle voulait rester avec nous c'est
ça qui est extraordinaire
je crois que depuis qu'elle a quitté
djezzy à la vraiment changé rihanna
qu'est ce qui vous a plu qu'est ce qui
vous a le plus plu dans son physique
rihanna oui eh ben je trouve que l as la
peau toute douce
ça nous a fait du bien quand ici oui
mais avec matthieu delormeau trouve
qu'elle a un peu un sourire chevalin
d'en apprendre un peu sur ses racines